every law student is terrified of being
cold called by the professor in class
and as a result they spend so much time
reading their cases over and over again
and studying on the off chance that they
might get called on but there is a
better way so use this trick to
supercharge your studying to make sure
that you are more prepared for the final
and are prepared for any cold call
question your professor may give you
[Music]
every law student is afraid of being
called on in class being on the hot seat
and being cold called by the professor
can be a terrifying experience and as a
result we tend to spend so much time
preparing for class and reading and
rereading our cases but you know what
there's a better way so use this trick
to supercharge your studying in a way
that will actually help you on the final
exam but will also prepare you for class
so that you can answer any question your
professor throws at you
okay so here at legal eagle we call this
the flipped case method and here's why
the normal way of studying is this you
struggle through reading a case the
average reading speed is about 10 pages
per hour you try to figure out the point
of a case then when you think you have
it you reread the case then you write a
long brief including the parties the
procedural posture the trial court
decision the facts disposition etc etc
you write all of this crap down just on
the off chance that your professor
happens to ask you about some random
detail about the particular case then
maybe you go read a commercial outline
or a supplement if you're lucky and then
you just go to class and hope for the
best that is a bad way to study for
class number one it's totally
inefficient you're starting with the
really hard stuff first and then reading
the summaries later on top of that
you're focusing on all of the material
that is not going to help you on the
final exam in our other videos on case
briefing links down below we talked
about how so much time is wasted on a
standard case brief because almost none
of that information is going to be
tested on the final exam the final exam
is about applying the facts to the law
not about the rationale
or the procedural posture of some random
case from New Hampshire
what we recommend instead is this it's
the flipped case method the idea is
start with a supplement first that's
right you read your supplements and your
summaries before you read the case read
the summary first several of them if you
can and only then once you have a
general or sometimes even a very
specific idea of what the case is about
only then do you go into the case itself
so for example if you happen to have an
outline for your course and it happens
to be keyed to your particular case book
go directly to the summary of the case
you're about to read and read the
summary first or you can use Westlaw
Westlaw is an entirely underrated
resource in law school they have a whole
army of attorneys who are summarizing
the most important facts and
black-letter law of a particular case or
you can go to an old upperclassman's
outline or you can go to Quimby the
trick is to get an idea of the point of
the case before you start delving into
it one person said that reading a case
is like stirring cement with your
eyelashes it just goes so slowly but if
you know what you're looking for ahead
of time then once you start reading the
case you can go through it more quickly
now I wouldn't skim through the case but
I would certainly go faster than you
normally read because you know exactly
what you're looking for pay special
attention to the particular facts the
narrative of the story but most
importantly pay attention to the
black-letter law which you probably
already have in the form of the
summaries in the outlines and commercial
supplements that you've already read of
course not all cases are created equal
some are important only for a particular
statement of black-letter law and you
might never even learn the facts
themselves some are important only for
the outcome based on the facts some
cases are only important for the
historical value and you're never going
to actually use the facts or the
black-letter law in that case but the
point is in any of those particular
scenarios it's better to have an idea of
what you were looking for before you
delve into the case you'll retain more
and you'll struggle less and on top of
that you can skip the
long meandering rainbow case brief - you
can click the link below to download our
guide on using a three-point case brief
method that will have you writing case
briefs in just a sentence or two and
when you pair the three-point brief with
our flipped case brief method you will
just breeze through your homework
assignments and cold calls well believe
it or not even though you're working
less you'll be far more prepared than
using the standard method you'll already
have a good idea of what the professor
wants you to take away from the case and
you'll remember the facts of the case
and between the two that's 90% of what
the professor is looking for anyway
so use the flipped case method you'll be
able to breeze through your homework
you'll be able to write case briefs that
will go directly into your outline and
will better prepare you for class if you
want more tips on how to crush law
school you can click the link below to
our free guide you can also check out
our master class where we lay out
step-by-step how to crush every single
law school exam and how to think like a
lawyer and please subscribe to our
Channel we come out with new tips on how
to crush law school all the time so I'll
see you next time here legal eagle every
law student spends you know never look
dumb in class again make being afraid of
and as a result they study the N and
will make cold calling on the final but
will also prepare you for class